last week's heatwave gripped britain as
record temperatures hit tinder dry
conditions fueled wildfires this was the
aftermath
buildings charred and homes destroyed
the uk's infrastructure just couldn't
cope as air and rail travel was
disrupted and in the days that followed
grass fires continued
this is just some of the devastation
caused by the extreme heat and now
according to new research that
blistering heat wave was made at least
10 times more likely because of climate
change although scientists say that's a
conservative estimate because extreme
temperatures are rising faster than
climate models predicted
and that's causing concern among experts
without climate change they calculated
that this would have been an event that
might have happened once in a thousand
years they've calculated that with
climate change it was an event that
would have only happened maybe one in a
hundred years but i think that they'll
find that actually it's far more common
even now due to climate change it's
showing that things are happening more
quickly than we expect
what kind of devastation could we see as
a result of all of this in the future
we know that for the next 30 years
things are only going to get worse
anyway
because it won't stop until the world
gets to net zero emissions
but it also means that we are in
uncharted territory and we're in for
some nasty shocks and last week might be
just the first of several nasty shocks
we are going to experience
while the uk saw a startling new reality
during the heat wave none of it should
come as a surprise as scientists now
warn the consequences of the climate
crisis on this type of weather could be
worse than previously thought aisha
zahid sky news